[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and it looks
like we have some more info on the
upcoming unannounced movie black panther
tube this mainly centers around who the
villain of the piece will be and it's
big news for marvel fans and feels like
a long overdue announcement for what
could ultimately end up being one of the
most anticipated MCU movies ever made
throughout this video I'll be giving my
thoughts on the news as well as
providing the evidence to support it but
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything about
the reveal and haven't had a chance to
watch spider-man far from home yet then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for click in this video
now let's get into my breakdown of who
the main villain of Black Panther 2 is
okay so this news comes from the website
we got discovered who correctly leak
that shang-chi would be featuring an
appearance by the real Mandarin as well
as announcing that taskmaster would be
the villain for Black Widow both of
which were confirmed at the phase 4
panel announcement at San Diego Comic
Con so this definitely holds a lot of
weight the source states that the MCU
will be featuring an appearance from the
king of Atlantis Namor who will be going
head-to-head with Black Panther in the
upcoming sequel Namor in Wakanda have
always had a pre uneasy alliance in the
comics and there's been several
instances where both sides have gone to
war with one another it makes sense that
Marvel would want to bring their own
version of an underwater Kingdom and
it's ruler to the big screen and I'm
definitely excited to see if this
becomes a reality but what evidence is
there to support this outside of the
leak well marvel as we all know are
outstanding when it comes to
foreshadowing and Atlantis was teased
during Avengers endgame when a coy atoll
black widow that had been an underwater
earthquake off the coast of what candor
this could definitely be paying lip
service to the rise of the Atlanteans
who may be finally coming up from the
depths of the ocean to investigate why
half of their population has suddenly
disappeared this coupled with the leaks
definitely sets up a lot for the future
and Namor is a kind of character that
can easily fill the role of a villain
and a hero really well he's always
charged in head for
and if he's to feature in the film I can
definitely see him building an alliance
at the end of it this report is really
exciting and it comes in the wake of
rumors that Michael B Jordan will be
featuring it in the film on a spiritual
plane and that Kraven the hunter will be
introduced as a walk and in native from
a long exile tribe before going on to
feature as the main villain in
spider-man home alone that title might
not be right which comes in the wake of
the heroes and masking at the end of its
last film anyway I'm really excited to
see what comes from this and whether we
get an announcement of it at the
upcoming d23 Disney Expo panel which is
due to happen this month
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the news and if you think it will
happen or not comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video and
want more things to watch then
definitely make sure that you check out
my breakdown of the trailer of
Christopher Nolan's 2 net which will be
linked at the end I go over everything
that you need to know about the first
look as well as what features in it so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and is the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this also just want to let you know that
we're currently giving away a free copy
of Avengers endgame on blu-ray to one
lucky winner and all you have to do is
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the news in the comment
section below the one will be chosen at
random on August 10th and the blu-ray
will be shipped out from then whoever
gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like it's
scribe thanks again for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best not see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you